we're back on do you think Samantha
asked Cory Booker you are too accessible
via Twitter where should the line be
drawn you think you're too accessible um
look the job how many followers do you
have Cory about 1.3 1.4 million Wow
yeah I got almost two okay I got five
verses you're really you guys you're
live Wow top of a local politicians do
constituent services the old way of
doing that and which we still do is take
phone calls take emails go to community
meetings but now I have a way for tens
of thousands of my residents to get in
touch with me and for me it's great I
could crowdsource information so I now
know about a water main break before my
engineering staff does I know about
traffic lights go out before my traffic
engineer so I get information now
quicker because as a city we're working
together through social media to make
our city better you leave it on even
when you sleep I actually do because my
blackberry unfortunately things
emergency happened let's never get sleep
i i sleepy regularly but uh but look if
that's I'm on call 24 hours and if
something happens I've got to be
accessible yeah but but it's great
because looking at Chrysler you can't do
that if you become president
I doubt a Barack Obama is responding to
his tweets and Facebook page right now
but look when in a crisis
it helped me during the major snowstorm
or even recently during sandy it helps
me get help to people and I had people
from outside of Newark saying I'm
worried about my you know sister my aunt
that's not responsive and it helped us
to find people who needed help that we
wouldn't have found otherwise through
traditional means okay Jackie as a
reporter you focus on studying the facts
without imposing any of your political
bias how hard you train a neutral and of
course if people probably could guess
your father Congress former congressman
Kucinich you obviously have a liberal
pedigree in your blood it's true but I
feel like when you're so close to it
every single day you see that everyone
has problems so it makes it pretty easy
just to keep yourself in the center
because no one has the market cornered
on sanity or being correct or what that
sounds like
kind of false equivalency that your
father would really hate everyone has
their own kind of rebellion very good
right look I remember radon Chong ones
telling me my father so disappointed I'm
not smoking pot anymore but what is
really yeah say that knows not has
monopoly on the truth Jack Kemp was the
sort of the the vanguard of empowerment
zones a Republican that's helped bring
millions accept billions of dollars
worth of investment into inner-city
communities like mine so no side has a
monopoly on the truth they're not
necessarily equivalent but there's good
ideas coming from all corners of this
country and bad ones I mean really I
believe them all yes climate change one
sides got a monopoly on the truth yeah
there are new questions where you think
you have to look stop playing tennis and
Daddy there's a reason why there's a
reason why I'm a Democrat and that's
absolutely true right as soon as you
shut down fifty eight million Americans
who voted for the other party and say
there's nothing you have to offer
contribute to our to our efforts to go
forward then you've really in my opinion
you've undermined the ability for us to
be address yeah but yeah yes I know I
mean it's also a problem reaching out a
little too much and pretending that the
other side has a point when they don't I
mean this is my thing about guns I mean
Oba every Democrats to say you know what
we love blowing the brains out um yeah
yeah nice we're real men and we're
sportsmen what could be more sports like
than blowing the holy [ __ ] out of a bird
right and and and the fact that look I
see that I was frustrated that the word
poverty wasn't talked about in the last
election but for me just very
pragmatically let me give you an example
we brought the Manhattan Institute which
is a right-leaning thank tank in New
York City together with local activists
and others to create programs for men
and women coming home from prison they
saw it as a chance to lower government
expenditures and do things that are
really popular on the right but it's
created programs in Newark one of them
which is reduced recidivism rates from
in their 60s to 7% and so this shows it
a partnership when you can find that
nexus you can jump Ward when you can
bring people together around a common
idea okay but you know this idea that
you can really reach no 58 million yes
you can reach some of them a lot of them
you can't I mean the people I used to
complain all of last year about the
bubble every week we did a segment
called dispatches from the bubble I
thought maybe they lost so bad they
would retreat from the bubble no they're
just making the bubble thicker do you
know that it was in the news today there
is now a tea bag or face book because
they do not want to hear any of the you
know the some wiseass
giving them the facts so they created
their own face book where they're able
to hear the truth I mean Hillary Clinton
had it right they don't live in a world
that's based on evidence and I don't
know how you deal with people like that
I really don't know not look neither do
I but I do I am encouraged I know you're
you might have a similar cynical take
that after this election the the issue
of immigration is now moved it's moving
forward in a way that it wasn't before
there's and I lost well that's exactly
right but but it wouldn't happen unless
people saw the whether it's for
political cynicism that this is not
going to get us reelected national
offices or they began to realize what
the data says is if you create the right
kind of immigration reform you create
more economic growth who create more
opportunity for everyone so I'm saying
that for years
right and and folks have been stubborn
and not listen um but but again you've
got you can't shut off the half of the
country or two-thirds of the Kinetico
you've got to figure out ways to reach
out all right this week Bill Gates said
that the biggest plague in America was
education or the lack of do you agree
and if not what do you think is the
biggest issue well that's certainly one
that affects every other issue because
if people are not educated about an
issue they can well a good education is
also the key to economic mobility
poverty specifically with with minority
communities um we don't call it a
dropout wait we call it push out rate
cuz you're just it's not it's not set up
for them to be successful and so I think
education is absolutely number one issue
we should focus on more than about five
years ago I've ever done
amazing speech by : Powell in a small
group he was talking about nuclear for a
Shinto war in Iraq
I'm terrorism and somebody had asked you
know what's the biggest threat to our
democracy in the next 50 years he didn't
miss a beat he goes our inability to
educate our population and then he went
on about the challenges in America and
so Mackenzie has this amazing study that
they did that talked about the
disparities in education or inability to
close them and what is the impact is to
our GDP and measured it about two
billion dollars there our failure to
close the achievement gap between
minorities in this country not
minorities and if you think about it
this was the 2012 last year was a
historic year nobody really talked about
it but it was a first year in American
history
that more minorities are being born than
people in the majority which is a
celebration of our diversity the problem
is is if we keep educating have the same
education outcomes in the future the
people who will be 18 years from now
will be relying on to produce for us to
create jobs for us lot of ya won't have
the education and also education the
educational cycle has the most points of
intervention so if you missed out on
early education you can intervene at a
certain point in a beaut so you think
they were lost after a certain but no
this is business it depends if you're a
minority you're scientists of the brain
isn't it true that if you don't use them
very early they're gone well both are
true there are critical periods for
certain things where it's easiest to
learn those things then and if you don't
learn those things then you actually
can't learn them so if you have it for
some reason you know you don't your
senses aren't integrating with the
environment the first year of life you
you will be functionally blind even if
you know everything is made normal after
that look at some real activists in this
in this country's history where
african-american slaves who the during
of abolition who didn't have the formal
education but found ways to educate
themselves and become some America's
greatest leaders there's always hope
there's will always hopefully al but an
opportunity to - there is give me the
child and I'll give you the man and and
one of the great penalties we are paying
in this country is that we have an
attitude in arguably half of the country
toward raising children and the
homeschooling movement I think is a
pretty ominous in terms of what it's the
facts it's filtering out and the
craziness it's
important from the first century and so
you you know you want people to have
their Herat their cognitive horizons
really expanded as early as possible and
we I agree with that but that's not to
say you cannot intervene at a later time
oh no I mean they've been people
incarcerated that come out and learn
another language or new you know what
you say out in front of real time right
if there's any message that we want to
get to the audience is if you have a
toddler a baby not an infant even if
it's still in the womb get in front of
the TV a-- close when a real-time is on
its gonna learn another language but
very much everybody
Real Time with Bill Maher side a night
attend massive buildings guests or
questions right after the show at
hbo.com